I am really excited Hillary Clinton is
here former senator former first lady
former Secretary of State look at you
Wow I can't even believe it there you
are
can I just stare at you for a while this
is so exciting for me yeah I'll let you
get you'll see you don't know yet
thank you I mean I don't know if you
read this piece of mine but um my
fantasy was not only to meet you but to
tell you what a hero you were to me and
how special you are to me and your level
of expertise and everything you've done
to sit here and get to tell you that is
very exciting for me well thank you and
I was a I was such a big supporter of
yours even going back the first time you
ran for president when you were running
against Obama and people forget how
close that really was it was it was
really touch and go as to who was going
to really get the nomination that's
right and I didn't until you know in the
2016 campaign yeah right yeah in the
2016 campaign
yeah but you know I have so much too
talked about but but you know yet
because to me you had the experience
that I wanted in a president and when
and even when you were Secretary of
State Henry Kissinger said you were like
an incredible secretin and he is the
gold standard the guy's a brilliant guy
right right I mean all of the work
you've done and all the public service
that's what I want in a president
I need somebody proven well we do need
that don't we we do need it we really do
need it I know and well first of all
let's get this out of the way you've
written this book with your daughter
right the book of gutsy women right and
I was shocked
no Oprah you know we left out some of
the best known people like Oprah or
Michelle Obama for example or Angela
Merkel could they get enough well we
thought that you know first of all they
do a great
speaking for themselves and everybody
knows they're gutsy right
what is gutsy mean to be a gutsy woman
it means having that determination that
persistence to not only achieve
something for yourself but also to make
a positive difference for others you
know I'm interested in people who are
successful and there are many of them
obviously men and women but I'm
especially interested in people who
overcome unbelievable obstacles because
they believe in something bigger than
themselves I was thinking this book is
like an award show like it is Hillary
would I call you madam secretary or what
I call you senator
I think it's Madam Secretary right yes
or Hilary no forget Hillary I'm not
going to we don't know we don't know but
it's Madam Secretary right yeah that's
the latest thing right that you always
take the latest thing and and although
being a senator is very cool
it's really cool wait is it weird for
you when you're a senator and you go
everyday to the Senate and you and it's
and there's not that many senators so
you get to know them on a personal level
and you're friendly with them but allah
then you announce you're gonna run for
president and they're so scummy to you i
mean nasty is it mind-blowing to you to
have to absorb that kind of betrayal
it's surprising sometimes and you know
what really has surprised me more than
anything is because you're right it's a
hundred people and you're in little
elevators with them you're on the floor
the senate late into the night
these mom used to do things they don't
do much now but it used to be that you
were constantly there you were working
on things eat lunch with them and it's
intense and you're making coalitions all
the time howard so sometimes you know
senator x will be against you but then
tomorrow you've got something that he
can really help you on and you join
forces and I worked with practically
every Republican when I was there for
eight years and then when you decide to
run for president and you just turn on
the TV there's some guy who's actually
like a friend of yours who you consider
that you know they admire you
yet they go on and right away it's like
they're there they're screaming about
yeah but you know there's like a
spectrum you expect some of it you know
some of the Republicans that I served
with never said a bad word about me I've
never said a bad word about them a lot
of them do the obligatory well you know
she's a Democrat I'm a Republican so
obviously I have to say something but
then there are those who have kind of
fallen off the edge and have so changed
their personality in my view their
politics like a Lindsey Graham like a
Lindsey Graham like is he blowing your
mind now because he's a completely
different guy he you know I traveled
with him because he was you know a very
good buddy of John McCain who I admired
and and liked enormous ly so I traveled
all over the world with McCain and
Lindsey and other senators and Lindsey
was good company he was funny he was
self-deprecating he also believed in
climate change back in those days man
yes well you would say I'm concerned
about the future for my children well he
doesn't have any children but he was
concerned about the future yeah
absolutely and so I saw him as somebody
who you know had been working to try to
figure out what he believed and how he
could do things as he sold his suit to
the devil I don't know the answer to
that I think that's a fair question
however and and what I don't understand
is how he went from being the friend and
and the you know real confidant of the
Maverick John McCain who you know I
didn't agree with politically but I
found him to be a man of integrity as a
man of you know real strength of
conviction the guy spent five years as a
prisoner of war
you ever been to Hanoi have you seen
that cell he stayed in for five years
it's a tiger cage got it I mean it's
unbelievable
and so I admire John I became really
friendly with him I felt like he was a
true friend
and so then Lindsey all of a sudden you
know John McCain tragically dies too
soon after standing up for health care
which was astounding and so in character
for him and now you know I don't know
what's happened to Lindsey Graham I I'll
be
honest with you I haven't talked to him
in long he wrote you know how Time
magazine has like the top 100 people all
that one year back in a couple of years
ago when I was in it he wrote the
tribute to me and then now it's like he
it's like he had a brain snatch you know
like if you saw him I don't know where
you would run into it like that but I
assume if you saw him would you even go
over and say hello to him maybe you
would I don't maybe he wouldn't I mean
he has been vicious to you well and to a
lot of people I mean it's not just me I
would say would you be cordial I I
probably would try to be yeah I would be
you know I went to the inauguration days
of my life I am assuming with that I was
thinking about you that day I was
watching you more than I was watching me
rump first of all I don't even know how
you get past you've got three million
more votes than I got it right in my
mind you won the election the Electoral
College I can't explain that I don't
under more who felt it was his rights
we're gonna be denied but the majority
of the people in the country voted for
you you got the job done great when you
stand in there watching this guy uh what
the hell is going through your head why
are you just I would imagine you were on
antidepressants that day you know how
here's how I felt about it
I mean obviously I was crushed I was
disappointed and I was really surprised
because I couldn't figure out what had
happened and you hadn't even written a
losing speech when you lost that now you
ain't only victory in my know and and
every everything was pointed in that
direction so when he's going to be
inaugurated I was going as a former
first lady right that was the reason I
was there I was no longer in the Senate
I was a secretaries of state don't
usually attend so I was what your sense
of duty is my husband was president I
was first lady and this is what we say
to the country there's continuity that
is exactly how I felt and a lot of
people said to me don't put yourself
through that don't go and I said look I
ran for president because I love this
country
I wanted to serve this country I thought
I would have been a really good
president
I want here would have been spectacular
well your alberene yeah I hope our own
affairs yep but I'd be crushing NATO
right now I don't think so no no we need
them but are you standing up so so I
said to myself I said to everybody who
talked to me about it look I hope he's
gonna be a better president then I think
he will be I'm worried about it but I'm
gonna do everything I can as I told him
when I called him you know that terrible
night wow I did I said you know I said
look you know Donald I want you to be a
good president I will do whatever I can
to help you so you know we're in that
generation or was he assort was so
shocked he couldn't he was shocked right
and so when I got there you know go
ahead get out there you put on the best
face possible and I'm you know bill and
I are sitting with George and Laura Bush
and then he started on that speech which
was so bizarre and that's when I got
really worried I thought wait a minute
it wasn't rational it's not rational but
it's also not it's not politics it's not
what a president does a president is
supposed to try to reach out to people
who weren't for him or her you're
supposed to say okay I'm gonna be the
president of everyone those who
supported me and those who didn't
because we're gonna pull the country
together I'd hoped that I would hear a
little of that I didn't hear any of that
and then that carnage in the street and
the dark dystopian vision I was sitting
there like just wow couldn't believe in
george w bush says to me well that was
some weird [ __ ]
and and don't you think that these guys
in the republican party who were even
running against him in the primary who
had horrible things to say about him do
you think they secretly look at
something like that a moment like that
and go oh my God we're in for a horrible
scene or or do you think they're all and
I don't know I don't think they were all
in in the beginning I think that they
were still trying to make sense of it it
was the ones that I knew but a lot of
the ones who have spoken out against him
have decided to leave politics
that's right they speak out then they
say they're retiring but isn't that
cowardly I think it is yeah that's why
we hired well first of all Howard it's
not just these are not just political
differences look if I had lost to a
normal Republican I would have been
unhappy right but I wouldn't have had
that pit in my stomach like what the
heck what is going to happen what's he
gonna do next his impulsiveness his
vindictiveness where does this lead so I
think that a lot of Republicans also
thought oh we can control him we can
manage and we can do this and I think
what they now have to be considered is
just you know cowardly are we what goes
through your mind when he's got these
people revved up lock her up lock her up
lock her up you know even now it's still
lock her up are you are you afraid for
your own life honestly honestly I have
been in the past
and remember some months ago the guy who
was inspired by him started sending pipe
bombs around yeah you know to me to
former President Obama and others so
clearly he he just incites these these
deep irrational and unfortunately
sometimes violent emotions some of the
people who have gone into synagogues and
and churches and Walmart's and other
places and shot them up and murdered
people have clearly been unleashed I
don't want to say it's a direct cause I
don't think that's fair but people are
amped up people are amped up and there's
always been look human nature being what
it is there's always been a lot of you
know emotions that people have biases
prejudices attitudes anti-semitism
racism whatever it is but you're
supposed to in a civilization try to
keep that down I mean that's part of the
job of leaders and it's also the part of
the job of self disciplining yourself
you know you can say okay yeah I may not
like that kind of person but I would
never say that or I'd never do that
but he has made it possible for all the
worst impulses it's like Pandora's box
lift the top off and things start
flooding out that's difficult to get
back into the box there was something
sweet I read I don't know if it's true
the night of the election you know and
and I can't imagine the despair you were
feeling I mean but going through a
campaign first of all when I think about
these campaigns brutal they are brutal
you know what I think is the most brutal
part and this is an outsider looking in
when you have to sit and do like
Saturday Night Live and do these comedy
sketches you're not a comedian yeah
you're a very serious woman you're an
academic if and I mean that it would
praise you went to Yale you're an
attorney you have served presidents you
have you've done some incredible you've
been a United States Senator you cared
about health care you cared about all
these now you're running for office and
you gotta go eat hot dogs at the hot dog
contest and all that stuff is such BS
and when I'm watching on Saturday Night
Live with these sketches I know you're
being a good sport because you have to
show your personality and your self
effacing and all this stuff but it's got
to be a nightmare for someone like you
it's got to be you know it's outside my
comfort zone let me be honest nonsense
well it is nonsense but like you know
Saturday Night Live I've always enjoyed
going on even though it's not easy for
me because you're right I'm not a you
know comedian by any stretch of the
imagination so I don't mind that at all
I don't really mind that I I like doing
things that other people enjoy and
appreciate so that's not a problem what
I find most challenging is you know
politics has to be entertaining to a
certain extent because you got to
attract people's attention you know
they're not you know professional
entertainers you know like you are but
they are you know people have to have
that personality okay I get all of that
and I'm you know I'm willing more than
willing to try but what I really don't
understand is how we have almost
trivialize politics to the point that
it's about nothing but entertainment I
mean the coverage of it is so
superficial and these are serious issues
I mean these are in many instances you
know
like a game show it's like a game show
and the consequences are on the people
who are going to be affected by who gets
elected and what they decide to do you
know what I want you to speak about a
game show I used to have this fantasy
when I would watch you debate Trump uh
you know I was saying to myself I wish
you would take out a map and say Donald
point to where Russia is I had this
fantasy wanted to to see you do I wanted
you to say name the president of you
just wanted to you know what I mean yeah
I wonder if he could find Texas on the
map no apparently not because remember
he said the wall was going to be along
Colorado the problem like there was a
moment when Gerald Ford ran and he
screwed up something about Eastern
Europe I forget what the thing was but
there was that moment where people said
Gerald Ford doesn't understand the
basics of geography or history and like
a game show I wished Alex Trebek would
have walked out and asked you guys a
couple of basic questions yeah and to
see who could actually answer them you
know you know Howard that's a really
interesting insight because I kept
thinking okay we're gonna get to the
debates and the debates are going to be
very determinative like you were talking
about Gerald Ford and and I've watched
presidential debates and and you can see
moments when oh my gosh the audience
goes you can just tell right and so I
thought okay he won't be prepared he
won't know he'll just stick with the
same stick on and look by you know all
these measurements that they do I won
these debates but it no longer matters
as much and does that's what bothers me
is like okay you were almost too nice
well you know I I was I don't I don't
know if I was too nice but I was
certainly you know very careful and the
reason is look I grew up at a time when
if if you were gonna get through a door
as a woman you did not react to anything
you know I remember taking the law
school exam at a huge hall at Harvard
and there were in
hundreds of men and there was like maybe
fifty women and we were in this room
waiting for the test to start and I was
sitting with some my women friends who
were there with me and all of a sudden
these young men start harassing us like
what are you doing here you have no
right to be here and it was really it
yeah and it was during the Vietnam War
so they were saying things like if you
get a slot then I'm gonna get sent to
Vietnam I'm gonna die it's gonna be your
fault and I mean just guys say that to
saying it they were saying it to us and
so what did we all we just put our head
down like okay yeah take the test you
sure you can do it
and so throughout a lot of my both
professional and public career you know
people said oh I don't know where I
don't know where part of it was that
training like okay you're a woman trying
to do something that not many other
women or any women have ever done you've
gotta stay focused don't get distracted
guys are gonna be trying to say this and
and do that you just keep going and so I
understand that in a way that works to
your detriment because reverential to
even this guy who's looming behind you
on the stage yeah because if you suppose
and I thought a lot about this
afterwards suppose I had turned around
and said you know back up you creep
you're not gonna intimidate me the
headlines would have been lost her you
know calm you know chess switches into
being angry right it would work again it
would have worked against me and then
the you know and then the you know all
the pundits would have said well she
can't take Donald Trump house you're
gonna take Vladimir Putin so I I'm not
unaware you've got this dialogue going
on in your head back and forth why we
member when you ran for Senator of New
York Giuliani was originally gonna run
against you and he got prostate cancer
he stepped out this guy lousy oh yes yes
yes
and I remember Lazio walking over on the
way I think I remember did him walking
over to your side where you were on the
podium and he came into your space right
connects guys do this with you all the
time well because they know that that's
one of the ways to shake women so that's
a great that's another great example so
Gary we're on the debate stage we were
in Buffalo actually right and
all of a sudden you know he is making
some demand like he says I want you to
sign this pledge right now and he walks
over and I just stand there and I just
look at him so this would have been 2000
so it ends and all the male pundits said
oh my god he really gave it to her this
guy walked right into your space and he
he just took like like he was like
sucking the air out of the room and I
thought there's not gonna be a human
being or vote for this guy actually he
lost you know handily but and you won
but the the switch didn't happen till
the next day when women started speaking
up right the men all on the TVs who were
analyzing it and in the press we're like
oh wow that was impressive
the next day women are saying who does
he think he is well I thought when Trump
was invading your space yeah but you
know it's so true what you say I never
looked at it that way because you're a
woman you kind of have to figure out how
to negotiate with men and how to deal
with men and when they do all this stuff
is because like in my mind I'm thinking
like a guy I think you go out to this
debate and you turn to this guy yeah
it's quite simply why won't you release
your taxes what are you hiding right and
then when I give you some [ __ ]
answer I'm not leaving right I want to
know I don't care about anything else
I'm running for president
I've released my taxes why won't answer
the question why won't you I'm under
audit no you're not mm-hmm you know but
maybe a woman just like it you got to
figure out every angle how to play this
thing well I think that it may be
changing a little bit and and I hope
that it is because it makes it really
difficult if you're a woman on the
public stage it's not just politics it's
everything media business you name it to
know how to respond in those situations
because we just haven't had that much
experience I mean when you say as a man
I could do this is because you know
there are all kinds of models that you
can point to right I remember I used to
trial lawsuits a hundred years ago and
it was so funny to me because I would
try cases with and against all different
male lawyers I mean they'd be trial
lawyer with a trial lawyer
they'd be tall they'd be short they'd be
fat they'd be thin they'd be well
as they'd be schlumpy they'd be
everything right but there had not been
women lawyers in a lot of these
courtrooms and so when I would go
because I was in Arkansas and I would go
into these small you know county
courthouses they loved you well I mean
one day I'm trying a lawsuit in North
Arkansas and all of it you know we take
a little break I come back and there
were like five guys sitting there in
camouflage why I turn well that's what I
didn't know you're sitting there waiting
for the trial to start again so I said
to the bailiff I said are these guys uh
you know they're on the deer Woods and
they came in from camp to buy some
supplies and they heard there was a lady
lawyer in town so they came to watch it
was like the talking dog him of that
generation where it was the first all
the time I remember trying another
lawsuit and the trial was supposed to
last a day so I you know driven up early
in the morning I was gonna turn on go
back and something happened the trial
was gonna go on
I had no clothes and so I said well you
know judge I hope you don't mind I'm
gonna be wearing the same thing tomorrow
that I wore today you look nice you look
pretty but if you want to come over to
my house my daughter's about your size
you can borrow her clothes I mean it
there was just all these new kinds of
whoever sings about what a guy is going
to be good Oh Jason trial where the
female lawyer Marcia Clark had to do a
makeover she was getting so criticized
for how she looked what she where what
what you were what her hair looked like
well you know Robin I mean you know this
because you're a professional and you
know we are getting to a point where
there are enough different role models
now so that you don't have to have some
preconception that you have to meet a
stereotype that people impose upon you
but it still is tough it still is a
challenge and because it almost sounds
like you had no there was nothing you
could do that was right well I think
there's a lot of that and people you
know I'm now watching this current
presidential campaign and I'm read
research and I look at you know what
people say
and you know there's still these double
standards let's just be honest there's
double standards and and you know if you
want to compete at the highest level in
whatever your area of interest is you
just gotta figure out how to absorb it
and deal with it so if you had have
advised these people let's say I don't
know who's gonna get in termination you
are you are you in favor of anyone over
anyone or you just win that's all I care
about
so that's tricky it is tricky and do you
everything what do you think Biden could
win well the polls say he can right so
do you think he could get the nomination
or is the party going to left and
they're looking for a Bernie Sanders and
uh I think it's too soon to tell because
nobody has voted or caucus so I think
that right now according to the polls
Biden is going to get the nomination but
that's you know a long way off and then
he can win the electoral college because
remember it's not the popular vote don't
you think they need a middle-of-the-road
kind of candidate I mean anybody can get
a general election it's a process of
addition you know you want to take the
people who are already for you and add
to them and that's tricky because the
other thing that's going on now is 24/7
news coverage right I mean it never ends
and everybody is a self-proclaimed
photographer because they have their
cell phone and I mean you know you you
yawn or you you swallow something the
wrong way whatever the problem might be
all of a sudden it's everywhere so
people just have to understand the
environment in which we are I may not
like it and wish I wish that were
different but it is a reality